fiston en bas bonjour merci de nous
avoir rejoints dans la matinale de rtl
or on le disait cela fait un peu plus de
deux semaines 1 que la ville de beni
notamment est agité par les
manifestations anti monusco
pourquoi ces manifestants ils réclament
le départ immédiat des casques bleus de
l'onu c'est quoi les raisons précises
alors ça fait presque époque la ville
des béni la région du territoire qui
porte également les mêmes noms est
caractérisée par les théories des civils
des m'attaquent
et tout cela notamment alors qu'il ya
une présence un forte des casques bleus
de la monusco qui accompagnent l'armée
nationale congolaise dans la traque de
ces de cette milice islamiste
alors face aurégan des violences atroces
lille ou à des groupes des prêcheurs du
mouvement citoyen ont déclenché des
actions à plein au départ des casques
bleus de la monusco pour son
inefficacité et donc si tu as étape est
la manifestation notamment une grève de
plus de dix jours que beaucoup des
manifestations se sont observés dans les
villes de béni et butembo et de goma et
qui vivent essentiellement de la mission
de l'onu en rdc
alors qui sont ces personnes qui
demandent ce retrait des soldats de
l'onu est ce qu'il ya un combat
politique derrière ou absolument pas
alors la plupart de ce mouvement sont
opposés des jeunes habitants de la
région qui se sont regroupés au sein de
mouvement citoyen et des groupes de
pression
ainsi des mouvements sont ni à la suite
et qui appelait notamment à à
l'alternance politique c'était des
mouvements
en démocratie et comme il ya eu élection
dans en ait conscience politique et
moment là ces mouvements ont pu
réincarner leurs huîtres à une li chi
qui appellent aux biens de la communauté
notamment des questions sécuritaires
sont au coeur de départ aidé toute
démarche des mouvements citoyens encre
et de ses courbes dépression et pourquoi
la monusco elle n'arrive pas à remplir
sa mission et 3 n'arrive pas à endiguer
finalement la présence de groupes armés
alors les mandants de la monusco
or et 9 les chaque année a toujours dit
comme pour l'essentiel la protection des
populations civiles et notre moral a
fait cette mission belloni à une brigade
d'intervention qui a été mise en place à
fendre qui a un mandat qui est plus
difficile que la monusco qui l'appelle
reygadas pouvoir notamment engagé de
combat contre les groupes prévenu qu'au
petit croquis qui me la région
malheureusement la configuration de
cette mission et même de cette brigade
ne permet pas à celle ci de pouvoir
répéter car la monusco avance notamment
un alignement au sein de deux opérations
distinctes pu confirmer à l'air vissi
des commandants qui sont sanctionnées
notamment par les états unis par l'union
européenne comme étant en frère à la
collaboration avec l'armée congolaise
il arrive également à une question très
difficile notamment du commandement de
la brigade qui devrait être indépendante
de la mousse pour les filles est
incorporé à la naissance des nations
unies en rdc et donc il devient très
difficile à danser contre x à cette
force gibbons et hill pouvoir imposer la
paix à l'est de la r dc et le gabon sur
la question du prix
la monusco a toujours ici pas trop
agressif parce que pour elle il pourrait
y avoir des femmes des enfants mais
également vis steve hill pris en otage
par ces groupes armés dans ses paroles
alors quelle est la position du
gouvernement de kinshasa face à ces
manifestations
comment réagit le gouvernement alors
pour l'instant il est très difficile de
pouvoir lire la réaction du gouvernement
parce que la république démocratique du
congo venez de passer presque deux mois
son gouvernement le nouveau gouvernement
qui a été mise en place à l'été à mort
nommé un ministre de la défense qui est
à plus de 40 ans de carrière au sein des
forces armées de latéralité effet
dernier dans les premières sorties
médiatiques un bon indiqué que l'action
du gouvernement sera axée sur la
restauration de l'autorité de l'état
alex müller d'ici notamment en se
focaliser sur la restauration puis la
discipline au sein du groupe star mais
parce que vous savez les groupes
d'experts internationaux mais aussi du
verre qui fit beaucoup les frais de
pointe et la complicité des parts avec
les modules pour ses armées de l'art et
démocratique du congo avec les groupes
qui sèment l'insécurité avec la
démocratique du congo
merci beaucoup fiston mamba ne nous
avoir éclairé sur cette situation en
république démocratique du congo je le
rappelle vous êtes journaliste à goma